The joe rogan experience.
And you know what's amazing is every podcast,
no matter how long I end up hanging out with the guest for another 45 minutes
afterwards and you're like,
they don't want to leave on the people don't want to leave.
And it could,
could've just kept going.
Yeah.
And well I do,
I do to a point.
I always feel like a lot of times,
cause I do the series show first,
I've already given me an hour and then I usually shoot a video with them.
I do this thing called talk your way out of it where I give people and uncle,
I'll do it to you right now.
Okay.
I'm going to give you an uncomfortable situation and in a split second,
you're going to have to talk your way out of it as if you're talking to the
person.
Okay?
All right.
Um,
are you go to the doctor's office and,
uh,
he's gonna,
he's gonna check you out.
So,
um,
he bends you over the table.
Okay.
And you got it.
Hey,
this is how I just,
I forgot the rubber gloves.
He walks out.
You notice that the medicine cabinet is opened.
You reach in,
you find a bottle of Vicodin.
You see it as he's coming in,
he's going to bust you.
You take it,
you stick it up your ass to hide it.
The doctor spreads you cheeks.
He wants to look at you and wants to look at your colon.
He puts his finger and he pulls out the bottle of Viking and talk your way out
of it.
Oh,
that's where that was.
Five words.
It's all you're going to Claire.
Oh,
that's where it is.
Thanking them.
Thanking maybe,
but no,
usually it takes like two minutes.
People talk around it.
They described you average five words.
Just go rifle.
C'Mon man,
you can't,
you're already busted.
I found a vitamin bottle up your ass.
You're a freak.
I did that.
I did that to know that that particular one I thought of,
cause my last show is with Natasha and I did that to her,
but it was in her pussy and she had her feet in the stirrups and she goes,
oh,
I was just tightening that for you.
Oh yeah.
Cheer up fucking human being.